not only are they getting more
authoritarian justin trudeau and more
dishonest gay pete they're also getting
more sadistic i mean this one really
is twisted this is a fake native
american elizabeth warren who is a
senator up in massachusetts
she is a communist and a socialist who
is all about public school although of
course she sent her kids to private
school she's also worth
67 million dollars i should write a
children's book about the socialists
worth 60 the 67 million dollar socialist
it sounds like something doesn't it uh
here she is and she's freaking out
because uh there are places where you
can go these pregnancy centers that will
sometimes convince you not to have an
abortion and she just loves dead babies
senator warren also taking aim at
pregnancy crisis centers here in
massachusetts
these so-called
crisis pregnancy centers
outnumber
genuine abortion clinics by
three to one she says women walk into
the centers believing they'll get
abortions instead they try to talk women
out of it she calls it a bait and switch
they are giving it over to people who
wish them harm and that has to stop we
need to put a stop to that in
massachusetts right now
they are giving it over to people who
wish them harm that is one of the most
sadistic twisted statements i have ever
heard
these people that work at these
pregnancy research resource centers
they're non-profit organizations and
basically what they do is what was laid
out right there women come in and they
say hey i'm struggling financially but
i'm pregnant or i have whatever it might
be my boyfriend abandoned me my parents
aren't happy about this i'm 16 years old
whatever it might be they offer free
pregnancy services they try to connect
you with community members they offer
financial services and they make sure
that you're going to get the medicines
that you need etc etc yes they try to
encourage people to go to term with the
pregnancy and then maybe adopt send the
baby to adoption or whatever it might be
rather than abort the baby
that is good
that is good it doesn't matter what your
position on abortion is it really
doesn't matter whether you are
completely pro-life or completely
pro-choice the idea that if there's a
way
that a woman wouldn't have to have an
abortion and a non-profit can do that
and volunteers can help that woman make
that decision that is good
but she really it's a bait and switch
they go in there thinking that they're
gonna have an abortion next thing you
know they walk out and they haven't had
abortion and then they have to have that
freaking baby
this is modern child sacrifice with
these people they are they are
completely out of control and what's so
twisted about their control is they
really believe it i mean uh that woman
elizabeth warren really believes
that she's the good guy in this
situation that if that woman who goes
there who's four months pregnant
18 weeks pregnant whatever it might be
walks in there and she goes in thinking
she's going to have an abortion and
she's feeling some kicking and we know
that there's a heartbeat and all of
those other things
and then she walks out and that baby's
not sucked out of her and dead
she thinks that that's bad
what else can you call that beyond child
sacrifice these people are absolutely
out of control
but speaking of out of control the man
in charge of these democrats is the
elderly gentleman known as joseph r
biden he was in the government for 47
years before becoming president of the
united states and apparently never got
anything done in those 47 years which is
why he had to run
as president
but he's trying to freak people out
because he knows he's not doing a good
job so instead of addressing any of the
problems he's really trying to scare you
about uh republicans
ask yourself this question what is a
republican platform going to this
campaign
no no i'm i'm in deadly earnest i'm not
trying to be plus just just a fact
so he's being deadly earnest what is the
republican
platform well i have a couple ideas here
that could be related to the republican
platform there are things that are
happening right here in florida which is
run by a republican named ron desantis
if you haven't heard of him great guy
how about lowering gas prices would that
be something that republicans basically
are into more than democrats of course
the answer is yes democrats want gas
prices to be high so that you'll be
forced to go into debt to buy an
electric car even though it's unclear to
them where electric cars are actually
powered from if they found that out they
might not be so into it but they're
telling us we have to in essence go
through this rough transition off fossil
fuels so we can get to aoc's green new
deal so i would say lowering gas prices
that's one thing republicans want uh two
how about lowering inflation you guys
print a whole [ __ ] ton of money all the
time then you blame putin when costs go
up and the rest of it and the you know
the dow jones and everything else is
crashing all that stuff the recession
that we're in although it hasn't been
fully declared yet um i would say
printing less money that would be a
republican position at this point
avoiding nuclear war that seems like a
good one any of you into nuclear war
anyone no i got big nose there nobody
wants a nuclear war but you know we are
in this war not war
with russia right now democrats have
been pushing for a no-fly zone democrats
are pushing to give them all sorts of
money democrats are pushing to give them
all sorts of weapons at some point when
the guy who the whole world has turned
against uh realizes that he has troops
on every side of him and we're just
funding this war even though we're not
in a war you know something like that he
might go oh you know i've got a nuke and
i'm kind of pissed so i would say not
getting into nuclear war would be a good
one how about having a border
and wanting to reduce fentanyl from
infecting all of our streets in our
cities a border would be good you guys
know that basically since biden has
taken over the southern border is
basically it's not a border you want to
come to america walk right in although
you can't come in from canada uh by
plane if uh if justin trudeau has
anything to do with that do about it um
how about this is the fifth one i'm just
going through a whole bunch here um how
about teaching kids not to hate each
other by race that is very much a
democrat policy at this point you guys
have gone full woke you love critical
race theory which is racism it's just a
repackaged racism so how about not that
that would be good uh i got another one
for you how about not sexualizing
children
i thought that one was pretty obvious um
but you guys are all into it right
you want
public school teachers and other people
other than the kid's parents to be able
to have private conversations with kids
about sex and gender identity and
sexuality and a whole bunch of stuff and
then hide it from parents you're a bunch
of weirdo freaks how about uh
republicans just aren't into that that
would be pretty good um how about uh
this is good as long as we're talking
about the school one how about
permitting kids to go to school
that's pretty good we may not like
what's going on in school but generally
sending kids to school and not having to
wear pointless masks on their faces
for a disease that's basically gone that
basically was proven that the masks
don't work in the first place and the
vaccines were unnecessary for kids et
cetera et cetera how about that that's
more of a republican principle than a
democrat principal and then finally i
would say how about letting people say
and believe what they want online right
because you guys love big tech
censorship right this administration we
know for a fact that this administration
they've admitted it several times they
actually go ahead and flag posts for
facebook so facebook can take things
down it's as close as you can get to a
direct violation of the first amendment
without maybe completely technically
tripping over that line so i would say
those are all republican principles at
this point it doesn't mean the
republicans are great it doesn't mean
they always live up to those principles
but it's a hell of a lot better than
what the democrats are doing so do not
believe joe biden when he says that